and I want to turn my attention to all
of the from all the craziness that's
happening in Europe and go halfway
around the world to one of France's
colonies in the Caribbean and that's
Saint Saint Domingue and I know I'm
butchering all of the pronunciations but
Saint Domingue and its modern name is
Haiti it is the western half of the
island of Hispaniola which was the
island that Columbus first stumbled upon
when he discovered the new world the
eastern half of the island that you
don't see here I've zoomed in on the
western half the eastern half is now
called the Dominican Republic at that
time is called Santo Domingo and it was
in control of Spain let me write that
down so Spain is here you probably don't
see my yellow that well and then on this
side France has colonized let me write
Spain in a boulder there you go Spain
heads Colin I had colonized the eastern
half of the island France had colonized
the western half and just to get us up
to speed on the history in 1492 Columbus
showed up and it was a Spanish colony
and I'm talking about just the western
side the eastern side continued to be a
Spanish colony but in 1697 it was
officially given over to the French but
it was a Spanish colony until then and
then 1697 until the period that we're
talking about right now which is the
late 1700s with a period of the French
Revolution it was a French colony
it's a French colony now you're probably
saying Sal why are you you know all of
this craziness is happening in France
Kings are getting toppled people are
getting guillotine
there's wars with all of the empires why
are you you know going all the way to
this side of the world and focusing on
this small little island well the big
answer I guess the main answer
especially from the perspective of the
French there's other historical reasons
why this I think is relevant but the the
major reason is that Saint Domingue at
this time was the most let me write that
in most in a most profitable slave
colony slave colony in the
world in the world
now these colonialists they cared about
profit pretty much all the time to a
large degree at this point in history
that's all they cared about but you have
to think about it remember what
precipitated the French Revolution or
what I think was a major factor was that
France was broke
France is broke so you have this little
island here it's a slave colony they
produce their plantations produce tons
of sugarcane hugely profitable business
anything that goes on in saint-domingue
will matter to France because France is
broken on a they're broke but they have
all of these wars with pretty much
everybody in Europe so let's go back and
remind ourselves of what was actually
happening in France at the time well
actually go back to France so 1789 you
had your convocation of the
estates-general the Third Estate they
were kind of a little peeved so they met
at the tennis court and they declared
themselves the National Assembly they
had the Tennis Court Oath so let me
National Assembly Third Estate actually
they declared themselves the National
Assembly then they were kicked out of
the room and then they had to do the
Tennis Court Oath were they they
promised that they would create a
constitution and they started talking
about liberty and fraternity and
brotherhood and all men are created
equal all of these great ideas of the
Enlightenment and while all that was
happening you happening you had this
businessman Vincent Vincent oj I don't
know if I'm pronouncing it right he was
a wealthy mixed-race so let me write
that down he was a mixed-race and he was
one-fourth let me African descent
African and he was 3/4 European or
French European descent and he was in
Paris on business and while he was there
the French Revolution and of this
convocation of the estates-general
started happening I said gee you know
what I'm a wealthy educated guy I own
land in what is now Haiti but in
saint-domingue at the time he actually
owned slaves want to be very clear about
this he
owned slaves as well and he's like you
know I am just as I'm I'm just as good
as all of these I guess you could say
purely European guys all around me but I
don't get equal rights now but all of
this great stuff is happening with talks
of a new constitution let me get in on
this and so he started lobbying with
several other I guess you could say
forward-thinking individuals he started
lobbying for equal rights so Vincent
O'Shea he lobbied for equal rights the
rights to vote and not to be treated
like a second-class citizen lobbied for
equal rights now at first they were kind
of ignored or you know the National
Assembly they wanted to do good things
but they don't wanna do something so
extreme as considering this wealthy
educated probably well-spoken individual
and equal so they were reported it but
eventually in March in March of 1790 so
1790 we're talking about March the
National Assembly passed an amendment
that had the wording that had the
wording all proprietors proprietors
ought to be and there's some other stuff
in between ought to be active citizens
well mr. Vincent O'Shea and his his
collaborators they say this is our
victory this is the wording that tells
us look anyone who's a proprietor I own
land I'm a proprietary proprietor it
says we have to be active citizens this
gives us the right to vote this gives us
the right to vote so he declared that a
victory for his rights or people like
his right and so he goes back to he goes
back to Saint Domingue and tells the
governor look all of this craziness has
been happening in France we have a
National Assembly and they've
essentially given me the right to vote
unfortunately the governor of Saint
gay Governor ignores him or essentially
doesn't listen to him ignores what he
has to say he says you know what I don't
care what's going on in France I'm not
going to give you and people like you
the right to vote so this obviously did
not make him a happy individual he seems
like he has everything going in his
favor even the National Assembly seems
to be going this favor but the governor
is him so he starts a revolt he starts
starts a revolt starts a revolt when he
returns and he's essentially rebuffed he
returned in October October of 1790
ignored by the governor so he starts a
revolt unfortunately his revolt wasn't
successful I want to be very clear when
he revolted
he wasn't revolting to abolish slavery
he wasn't revolting to give all black
men on the island the right to vote he
was revolting to give free men of color
who owned land the right to vote and
that was probably his mistake in the
revolt because I want to give you a
little sense of the demographics of
saint-domingue at that time there were
500,000 slaves of African descent you
had 40,000 white colonialists and you
had 28,000 28,000 mixed-race mixed-race
free men or of color or however you want
to describe them now if you're going to
start a revolt you're going to get some
subset of if you're starting a revolt to
defend only your right you're going to
get sub sub set of this 28,000 against a
very well-armed in power 40,000 now if
he had thought maybe I should speak in a
little bit broader terms he was
essentially trying to become a part of
this club but if he spoken maybe
slightly broader terms maybe he could
have tapped into some of the angst of
that 500,000 but he didn't and so his
revolt was unsuccessful and he was
captured and then in February February
February
1791 1791 he was executed so it seems
like all was for naught he went through
all of this trouble to get some freedom
he was ignored try to revolt his revolt
wasn't done that well he was executed
but it started to I guess simmer within
the the consciousness of the the people
of African descent at that time and
whether or not his revolt directly led
to what was going to happen over the
next few years it's unclear but it did
happen and he was he did at least he was
the first one that really did try to
start a revolt in a major way anyway
after he was executed in seventeen there
there started to be a little bit more
murmurings especially in the north most
of the sugar plantations were focused
around the north and obviously the more
plantations the more profit and there
was actually a voodoo ceremony that was
run by an individual whose name was
dutty Boukman and I looked for pictures
of him I couldn't find any unfortunately
there aren't he ran this voodoo ceremony
we essentially instigated a slave
uprising in Haiti or what was what is
now Haiti but in saint-domingue now
remember look at those demographics as
you could imagine if the slaves
themselves were to rise up against
everyone else on the island you could
imagine even though they might not be as
well organized or as well equipped as
the other members just by sheer force
they should probably do pretty good
and so in 1791 in August 1791 August
1791 an all-out slave rebellion begins
slave rebellion begins now you can
imagine this scares France you know
putting all side all the things of the
Revolution all of these new notions from
the Enlightenment here is your most
profitable colony in the world and all
of a sudden there's a revolt people on
both sides of the equation are getting
slaughtered plantations are getting
burned from the new government in
Francis point of view that's just going
to hurt their own profit and this is at
a time remember France is broke they're
at wars with other countries so France
sends a delegation headed by this guy
headed by this guy right there
his name was sung and I know I'm
butchering the pronunciations sontha
Knox Anthony Santen oh I don't know the
best way to pronounce it and it was him
plus six or seven thousand troops
six or seven thousand troops and they
essentially were sent from France to put
down the slave rebellion to kind of get
things back to the way they were and in
order kind of consolidate everyone on on
Frances side right here France France in
April 1792 so let me write this sense so
in April 1792 the legislative assembly
you might remember a new constitution
was created at the end of 1791 and that
entailed a new Legislative Assembly
ledges Legislative Assembly they
essentially gave full citizenship to all
free people of color full citizenship
so unfortunately Vincent O'Shea was a
little bit ahead of his time if he just
waited a couple of years he wouldn't
have had to revolt or maybe he helped to
precipitate this so it's not clear maybe
his revolt and then which maybe helped
precipitate the eventual slave revolt
which eventually might have helped the
Legislative Assembly come to terms with
this idea maybe he made it happen or
maybe it would have happened on its own
but they made full citizens out of
people free free people of color free
people of color
and they probably did that I mean you
could use kind of a positive or negative
spin the positive spin was this is
consistent with the ideas of the
Enlightenment and the revolution or if
you want to kind of view a more
strategizing view on it they probably
said hey all there's all this craziness
going on in Haiti if we can at least get
these people on our side we might be
able to properly suppress these people
over here and let's be clear many of
these mixed-race freemen of color they
own slaves themselves so from their own
self-interest they were actually very
similar to the white colonialist in
saint-domingue at that time so it cut
you know if they were a little bit more
a strategic about it it might have been
just to kind of consolidate the power on
the free people on the island or the
landowners on the island but they sent
that message with Santha know and 6,000
to 7,000 troops to get things back in
order but you might remember and even
that you know this did not make many
this made many people very unhappy even
on the island as you can make some of
those white colonialists at that time
they weren't the most liberal thinking
people and they probably didn't
appreciate this idea of free men of
color being able to have all of the same
rights as they did so there was
obviously a lot of a lot of antagonism
against this guy against Santha know
right there and then you might remember
that in February 1793 we saw that in the
previous video or in several videos ago
February 1793 you start having war with
Great Britain war with great war with
Great Britain and Great Britain had
control of this right here that is
Jamaica that is Jamaica just to be clear
and green right here this is Saint
Domingue
so that is Saint Domingue
and right here this is good this is
Santo Domingo controlled by the Spanish
so you had a big problem here is
something knocks right there
he's antagonized some of the whites he's
trying to put down
a slave rebellion or at least get things
back to normal
and all of a sudden you have the British
over here and you have a lot of these
white colonialists that start saying hey
you know what if France is going to be
like that we're going to side we're
going to side with the British we're
going to side with the British or we're
going to get help from the British and
we're going to use that help from the
British to essentially get our way back
in saint-domingue
now the Sante Knox who was as far as I
can tell he was of a more liberal
persuasion in that he was sympathetic to
the plight definitely of people of mixed
race and even to the plight possibly of
slaves themselves but also for strategic
reasons he he saw the writing on the
wall as well he said gee you know I'll
have five hundred thousand slaves and we
need to fend off the British so and this
is a pretty this is a pretty bold action
I mean this is in the history of slavery
this is actually one of the most
significant declarations in 1793 in
August of 1793 it might be a reflection
of his own ideas or it might have just
been because of the threat from Britain
Santha Knox or whatever Santha Knox sawn
the Knox declares freedom for all the
slaves declares freedom for slaves he
wasn't saying that they would have all
of the same rights as land owning men
but he's essentially abolishing slavery
and well this was initially he did it
just in the north so this was at first
just in the north but in September and
October he eventually extended it to all
of the French possessions in
saint-domingue now you can imagine the
slaves that were revolting this entire
time they're a little bit suspicious of
this gentleman he was it looks like sent
to Saint Domingue or what is now Haiti
it looks like he was sent there to put
down the uprising he shows up with six
or seven thousand troops he tries to
side with essentially the enemies of the
slaves to put down the uprising and now
all of a sudden when the British looked
like a bit of a threat
he's like hey I've I'm ending slavery by
myself I am just declaring slavery to be
over and they you know they've been
tricked before and they're saying you
know this was probably some type of a
trick just to make us kind of become a
little bit of passive so that they can
get back at us but and so their leaders
were a little bit suspicious of it but
then in February of 1794 February of
1794 this was ratified his declaration
was ratified by the National by the
French National Convention ratified by
French National Convention and by the
time word got to the slit or the freed
slaves or the rebelling slaves on the
island so now we're now in May 1794 the
rebel slaves leader and this is a super
important name to know Toussaint - sont
lova chor lo virture he was the leader
so he was the leader of the rebels and
he was a self-educated former slave
himself and actually he proves himself
over and over again to be one of the
best military generals and actually in
much of history in May 1794 Toussaint
L'Ouverture - I'll write his name twice
Toussaint L'Ouverture decides to
essentially join sides with the French
Republic join sides with Santha knox
joins with french french republic now
once again let's look at the numbers you
have two sont L'Ouverture he is
essentially the leader of the 500,000
newly freed slaves he is in charge
I mean this is essentially going this is
the military of the island he is now the
leader of the island so now he is
essentially he is essentially you can
almost view him as as the general or the
governor of the island of of this colony
but at the same time he you know he
despite the fact that he had very good
leadership qualities he also had a bit
of a megalomaniacal aside in a month
for himself and so he actually declared
himself governor for life so he did in
1801 1801 he issues a constitution that
declares himself declares himself
governor for life governor for life and
in his defense I guess I mean this
wasn't that unusual for this time in the
world I mean you look across the
Atlantic look what Napoleon is doing he
takes over the French Republic he
essentially is declaring himself Emperor
and what not for life and this guy says
hey you know I have the same right to do
it I've led these people to essentially
their freedom they trust me I'll declare
myself governor for life and ascent and
also in his defense and and this I think
also speaks to him being a step ahead of
many of the rulers at this time is that
he didn't have just plain old
slash-and-burn tactics he actually did
enforce a lot of discipline amongst his
troops and we'll see one of his
right-hand men the Saleen de sel I know
I'm pronouncing it wrong this aleene's
he was much more I guess savage with the
people that he was fighting against but
he but Toussaint L'Ouverture was very
disciplined and disciplined and when he
came to power he actually did not try to
get revenge on the mixed-race or on the
white plantation owners he realized that
hey you know what we are a new people in
charge of what is essentially a new
country or in his mind it's a new
country but let's not try to rock too
many boats let's try to kind of keep our
society going in some reasonable way so
that we don't just you know ruin
ourselves into oblivion and he also did
not
declare independence from France so
that's an important point too he wasn't
some type of you know true he didn't he
didn't want to completely disjoint
themselves from France so not no
independence he was just happy
essentially being part of the French
Empire but he himself will be the
governor well now you can there's
there's you can imagine on two levels
Napoleon was not happy and he remember
that in 1799 and especially 1800
Napoleon comes to power calls themselves
the first Council Napoleon Napoleon not
happy and he's not happy on essentially
two grounds one he's you know there's
this upstart here declaring himself
governor of the kind of governor for
life of this out no one can do that but
Napoleon the other problem that Napoleon
had is all of a sudden once you lose
five hundred thousand slaves and they
are now freemen and they can essentially
you not have to pay them maybe slightly
better wages instead of just making them
do it you want and just extracting all
the profits Fred the the island the
colony becomes much much less profitable
so in the back of his mind he also
wanted to reinstate slavery and we'll
see you'll see that he does it
explicitly later on so it doesn't like
slave freedom so he sends his
brother-in-law you need a you need a
dirty job to do you got to send someone
you trust
he sends his brother-in-law Charles
Leclerc Charles Leclerc with forty
thousand troops
forty thousand troops a Napoleon is
definitely taking the situation
seriously with forty thousand troops to
essentially take back the island from
Toussaint L'Ouverture and so you imagine
there's this huge battle that goes on on
the island of Saint Domingue or the
western half of the island or the part
that's controlled by the French and
eventually they start to get the upper
advantage and this it doesn't help the
fact that Toussaint L'Ouverture some of
his closest generals or his closest
aides when they kind of see the right
the wall when they see that this guy and
the next video I'll talk about how
barbaric some of the things this guy did
was but once once some of Toussaint
L'Ouverture general started to see the
writing on the wall they actually turned
on him they actually and one of them was
and this he actually ends up completing
the revolution but while he was fighting
for Toussaint L'Ouverture this is
jean-jacques Dessalines this lean him
and some of the other right-hand men -
Toussaint L'Ouverture he actually joins
the side of Leclerc Leclerc is kind of
you know making it look like he's not
trying to reinstate slavery he's not
trying to take citizenship away from
people of African descent he makes it
look like he's only trying to take lo
virture off of his high horse so this
guy says ok fine you know for the better
mint of of saint-domingue
I'm with you and at that point Toussaint
L'Ouverture is essentially in a very in
a very tough situation so Leclerc says
hey you know Toussaint
let's let's have let's have some
negotiations and maybe we can figure out
some way for you to assimilate you and
the people you're leading into
essentially you know Napoleon's what is
now turning into Napoleon's Empire so
Toussaint L'Ouverture being a kind of
upstanding individual who trusts people
and a man of honor he says well we know
this Charles Leclerc must be a man of
honor as well so he meets with them to
discuss you know kind of the terms of
assimilation well it turns out Charles
Leclerc was not a man of honor maybe I
could draw some devil horns on him right
there and he when Toussaint L'Ouverture
shows up by himself for a very civilized
meeting he gets some people to arrest
him capture him him and then send him on
a boat to France and essentially
Toussaint L'Ouverture
he dies in France in a prison so dies in
France dies in France so I'm going to
leave this video here it's kind of a
very sad moment you you have freedom for
the slaves temporarily you have this
major historic figure Toussaint
L'Ouverture leading the slaves and
trying to establish a new government but
then it gets violently suppressed by
Napoleon's henchmen by Charles Leclerc
his brother-in-law I'm going to finish
this video just with a quote from
Toussaint L'Ouverture because it kind of
foreshadows what's going to happen in
the next video so this is actually
something that he said on the boat to
France after being captured in
overthrowing me let me make the whole
quote here in overthrowing me you have
cut down in saint-domingue only the
trunk of the tree of Liberty
it will spring up again from the roots
for they are many and they are deep